I'm James I'm 17 and I'm pretty sure I'm
a psychopath when I was nine but my hand
they were deep fat fryer I wanted to
make myself feel something school was
beneath me but it was a good place for
observation and selection had a plan I
was gonna kill someone
hey Singh's gate in it's pretty [ __ ]
[ __ ] off trying to think I could fall in
love with him I thought she could be
interesting to kill so I pretended to
fall in love with her this is nice what
I thought probably he was gay he does
prick
let's leave the [ __ ] town I'm going
whether you come with me or not you in I
didn't know where we were going or when
I was gonna do this I punch my dad in
the face and stole his car and that felt
like a good place to start and the extra
funds they're throwing up right a banana
split to me it seemed that Alyssa had
some issues
[Music]
with James being with amiss that starts
to make me feel things
have you ever eaten a [ __ ] before a lot
the time you don't register the
important moments isn't happened let me
see that they were important when we're
back see both socks a bells take your
top off do you think is gonna explode
it's not a film I might be able to fix
it because neither here sure I can you
can still fix it
why is no one stopping probably because
you've got these hits out there are lots
of weirdos except over weirdos did you
want to live come on I am gonna be so
[ __ ] off if we get murdered
[Applause]
you